[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it was absolutely wonderful and it was
it reminded me of my childhood when we
were kids uh me and Ernie saw all if not
again most if not all the Friday the
13th films here and uh back in those
days you know on a Friday Saturday night
the theater was full because there were
no such thing as the internet and
streaming and [ __ ] like that there
weren't a lot of options and so in the
80s Friday and Saturday night this place
would be packed uh it's a Saturday night
and it's [ __ ] packed again it feels
like the 80s all over again man thanks
to everybody who came out tonight
[Applause]
um okay we uh met these cats before the
screening began but I'm gonna
reintroduce them uh for the folks at
home and then they're gonna introduce
you to everyone they brought along to
play with man uh sorry we started late
uh everything here kind of starts late
and then just keeps getting [ __ ]
later so we told on the internet we were
like we'll see you at 11 and [ __ ] 11
they were like what the [ __ ] and uh it's
midnight and they're really mad but it's
a free show [ __ ] off
um
uh okay kids uh you can't make a movie
without a producer and let's bring up
the producer Uncle creepy himself Steve
Barton get up here man
[Applause]
uh we'll bring we'll bring yeah well
I'll bring up Damien and hope you guys
bring him up and then um of course uh
the genius without whom we don't get to
see all that [ __ ] splatter what an
overachiever can't just [ __ ] can't
just write can't just direct has to do
this [ __ ] special effects as well man
uh give it up for the insanely talented
Damien Leone
[Applause]
all right kids who did you bring
introduce us to your buddies
all right Lauren Lavera Sienna herself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Miss Vicky Samantha scaffidi
[Applause]
Sienna's mom
yeah
Sarah Voight
[Applause]
Jonathan himself Elliot Fulham
and finally the last the last guy coming
up and we're gonna rotate a couple out
because there's a lot of us here but uh
these movies do not exist without this
man and his wife Mr Phil Falcone
[Applause]
okay everyone have a seat
gets comfy and whatnot
um
Damian take us into things uh before we
watched terrifier 2 we watched terrifier
uh as
uh filmmaker the first thing I was like
what the f how much that cost what was
the cost uh we went into that movie with
35
000 and at the end of the day yeah in
post it cost around 50 grand for part
one so 50 grand for part one and [ __ ] it
makes me feel so guilty clerks was 27
000 for 23 more thousand you made an
actual legitimate movie
um
should have [ __ ] kept going now that
was what 2016. yeah 15 I think we shot
it yeah and what was the experience like
you'd made some flicks prior to that
correct
I did I considered terrifier I wanted to
be my first official movie because it
was the first movie I ever wrote and
wanted to make in full but before that I
had a movie uh most maybe some of you
know called All Hallows Eve and that was
thank you
um
because I started many people maybe
don't know this but um I started with my
first official short film in like 2006
and that was the first time art the
clown was ever introduced so this was
like a long journey
um it wasn't like an overnight success
with terrifier too
um so it took it took a long time to get
from there to here when I made I mean
can I take this back from like the very
beginning
it's a little it's a little like
long-winded but so when I got out of
high school I said you know I naturally
I have to go to film school but I wasn't
really I took one class at the new
school University in Manhattan but I
went to the new school I took one class
it was an Aesthetics Aesthetics of
directing class I figured you know I
didn't really have money to go to film
school but I told my mother you know
could I just like take a class like
start see how it is right and I went and
um I wasn't really learning anything
they were showing me a lot of foreign
films like Fellini movies and things and
I was like this isn't really why I
wanted to get into movies I I love like
jaws and taxi driver and things like
they're not really showing me so then I
went back to my mother I said look
instead of going to film school would
you be willing to like max out some
credit cards and give me money to make
my own short film that I can start
putting into film festivals and that's
smart yeah yeah
um that could kind of like be my calling
card as a filmmaker and maybe somebody
will discover me and Hollywood will come
knocking on my door and be willing to
give me money to make a bigger movie how
far-fetched very far-fetched
so that's what wound up happening and
then it was like all right now this is
like my time to shine what's this movie
going to be how am I going to stand out
amongst other filmmakers so the only
thing I really had in my back pocket was
that I was also did my own special
makeup effects when did that begin oh uh
I would say well I've been watching
horror movies legitimately since I'm
three years old no joke do you remember
the first one you ever watched
um the early rotation was really Jaws my
mother took me to the movies to see The
Lost Boys when I was four years old wait
you saw Lost Boys at age four in the
theaters at four years old I feel so
[ __ ] old I Saw The Lost Boys in this
theater did you really yes
wait do you do you like remember the
experience absolutely I legitimately
remember the experience like it was
yesterday and it was like a [ __ ] rock
concert yeah yeah like one thing they
did back then like it it took a while
like they really built up the suspense
before you saw what they looked like
that was a big deal back in the day and
when they really like when they're in
the trees and they [ __ ] come out like
Kiefer Sutherland comes out of the
Shadows like the audience went [ __ ]
nuts when you saw and that was like
unprecedented and now that's what
vampires that's like the staple it's
what they look like but that was like
unprecedented what they looked like it
became the popular look of vampires
anyway like I remember that like it was
yesterday in that [ __ ] movie the um
so wait at a young age you're drawing
the horror and it makes you want to
learn how to do the effects as well no
so I I was I I could see it all makes
sense not quite like that so I was
always artistic and I would always draw
and make comic books my own little comic
books and stuff I was always very much
into playing with action figures I
always wanted to be locked in my room I
never wanted anybody to come in I was
always in my own little world playing
with action figures and things like that
but uh so since I was so into horror
movies and I already started loving the
slashers like Jason and Freddie so when
you rented Friday the 13th part six on
that VHS tape there was the Coming
Attractions to screen grates which is a
fangoria hour-long produced documentary
on Tom savini the special makeup effects
artist Tom savini yeah
and that was that was the first time I
ever saw what a makeup artist did and I
saw this guy being responsible for the
you know the dummy Jason puppet in uh
Friday 13 part four and he had his hand
up like the [ __ ] uh fluffy puppet
from Creep Show all these movies and
monsters that I already loved and I said
oh my God this is like three-dimensional
artwork this is the guy that creates the
monsters and I like a light that was
like a big light bulb moment I said like
this is amazing but I was still very
young I was like seven years old but I
knew I was like obsessed with that but
when I was 12 my mother actually took me
to the chiller theater horror convention
in Jersey yeah
so this is like
93 94 to actually meet Tom savini
because he was my idol for years and uh
so I got to meet him I was super nervous
and uh he was really cool and but we
talked for a little bit but
coincidentally a vendor there was
selling uh these starter makeup kits
these Ben and I makeup kits and these
real machetes that were dulled and they
had the [ __ ] Tom savini semi-circle
cut out which is a classic Tom savini
game put it right in the neck right in
the head yeah and uh and a bot I'll
never forget a bottle of mint flavored
blood and my mother bought all that [ __ ]
for me and I got home and I dove into
that makeup kit and the first thing I
learned how to do was make this very
realistic cut on my friend's faces with
liquid latex I would just put a very
thin layer and fold the skin on onto
itself and it created this amazing guess
and I would send them home to their
parents and we would we would lie and
say that we were playing football and
they hit their head in like the car in
the license plate and cut their head and
one of my friend's fathers had just
gotten home for from work and we did
this to him and he was like you
[ __ ] he's like I just got home
now I got to take you to the goddamn
emergency room and he like he got so mad
at his son and we totally duped him into
believing that and I got such a rush
from that that I fooled an adult and I
said you know like this is for me like I
am obsessed with makeup effects from
this day forward and I never stopped and
eventually I just hold on let's unpack
the poor abused kid who [ __ ]
whose dad was like your [ __ ] injury
is by ruining my evening uh yeah
um what what I find incredibly uh
charming and same you know where as
artists are always looking for
similarities in each other and [ __ ] like
dogs sniff each other's asses and stuff
you want to know how similar you are uh
this is how similar we were
um I loved Tom savini if I had found his
book Grand Illusions which he had
written years ago on the art of
prosthetic makeup that was the direction
I was gonna go long before I wanted to
be a filmmaker and [ __ ] all I wanted to
do was special effects makeup I too had
a little makeup kit but I wasn't good
enough to make gashes and [ __ ] all I had
was a folded knife and [ __ ] nose
putty I'd stick it in necks and [ __ ]
leave the folded knife and then pour
[ __ ] Karo syrup blood all over the
place problem is when you pour it on
wood floors that [ __ ] don't come up and
we would do it at people's house like
Debbie lepay's house and show her mom
came home and we were pretending to be
dead in the hallway and she was not
[ __ ] impressed at all because all she
saw was the [ __ ] red dye on the wood
and that never went away 10 years the
[ __ ] stained and [ __ ] that was my
dream was to do special effects and then
uh I failed at life so uh
your story is the opposite you [ __ ]
saw it went for it and figured out how
to do it what was the first major effect
that you did where you were like [ __ ] I
am in savini country
well like I said it was that honestly
that little gash that really got big
reason that's not savini that's not
saving cash
um there were a couple of things there
was a couple like moments where I found
this pair of like Groucho Marx
sunglasses with that squirted water that
was just like in one of my cabinets and
the first time I ever took that apart
and put the um I put that tubing into a
soap dispenser pump and put that behind
a knife and sprayed you know cut my neck
and sprayed blood out of that I was like
oh my God that was like another light
bulb moment like that's a Tom savini
classic gag you know but I think it was
like probably the first time I created a
prosthetic that I could put on somebody
that was like now explain from the
uninitiated what a prosthetic is sure
sure like anything in Walking Dead Lord
where you see just like the zombies or
um I mean it's like you take a mole to
somebody's face and then you sculpt in
clay what you want them to look like as
it's whether it's a zombie or a vampire
and you take a mold on top of that fill
it with either either foam latex or
gelatin you get a piece and you can glue
it onto their face so that was that was
a big moment and when I was learning
that it was way before YouTube or
anything like that so I had to like find
this three Series VHS tape that taught
me how to do it you know step by step so
that was that was interesting
um but yeah it was just always about
makeup effects and going back to the
first short film with uh with art the
clown so then it was like all right I'm
gonna create a short film that's packed
out with demons and creatures and things
like that and
there was there was oh you know when
you're an aspiring filmmaker at a young
age you know horror writer director all
you do all day long is just think of
these creepy scenarios you know just
weird circumstances things you could put
characters into and um I was inspired by
this Twilight Zone episode the original
Twilight Zone it's one of my favorite
shows of all time there's this episode
called Mirror Image where this woman is
all alone in a bus depot in the middle
of the night and just this weird [ __ ]
keeps happening to her like she'll look
at her luggage one moment the next
moment she'll look away her luggage is
in a different spot and then she'll go
up to the guy at the ticket booth and
she'll say you know what time is the bus
arriving and he'd say you know lady the
bus is coming you know in 10 minutes
it's the same time I told you it was
coming you know five minutes ago stop
asking me and she's like I've never
asked you this before and it turns out
that her doppelganger is in that Depot
with her and keeps [ __ ] with her and
making her like go insane and it's very
creepy and I just loved that atmosphere
and I said I want to recreate something
where a woman is in that similar
situation where she's confined in this
setting and some evil force is just
[ __ ] with her so I said I'll do
something where This Woman's alone on a
bus in the middle of the night just you
know going somewhere and at a stop a
clown gets on all of a sudden it won't
be a doppelganger it'll be a clown and
he gets on sits across from her and just
starts staring at her and it's just very
uncomfortable and then he goes into his
bag and he's hot and haunted her and
it's not immediately threatening but
it's getting more and more intense until
eventually he's trying to stick a needle
into her it's one of many weird creepy
ideas I had and I said that would be a
good way to kick off this short film and
then it became well what is this clown
what does he look like and at the time
Tim Curry's Pennywise was and still is
arguably the king of all killer clowns
and he was the archetypal yeah for sure
like the the archetypal killer clown and
I said if I'm gonna take a shot at the
Killer Clown he can't be anything like
Tim Curry's Pennywise because that would
just be totally disrespectful and I need
to do something different so I went in
the complete opposite direction and I
made I didn't make him colorful I didn't
make him you know he didn't have hair he
didn't have the bulbous red nose he
didn't speak so I have a lot to thank
Tim Curry's Pennywise for for visually
what art the clown looks like and
Visually you know art the clown that's
what a lot of people it's the first time
they discover the character I've heard
so many times when it was on Netflix for
the first time and nobody knew what
terrifier was I hear the story all the
time that they were just scrolling
through the horror section and then
they'd See Art the Clown's face and
they'd say I don't know what this movie
is but I need to check that out I need
to know what's going on with that
character so yeah that's pretty much how
it started but it's been a long journey
it was like two short films and they
were put into an anthology and then you
know this guy it was the only one to
come through because for a long time I
just wanted to make terrifier the short
film I wanted to put art the clown into
uh his own feature nobody he wanted to
give me money nobody believed in killer
clowns this was before Stephen King the
sequel to it came out and I remember the
producer of all house Eve I tried
pitching this to him I said you know all
house Eve has a little bit of success
could we make a a standalone art the
clown movie and he's like no it's like I
spoke to some people and clowns cannot
sell the movies like that's what
[ __ ] it it's just such a one of those
theories people like clowns don't work
move on and you're like what clowns at
work not anymore I'm the Arbiter of
[ __ ] clowns
that's it clowns can't sell a movie and
I was like all right I'm on my own and I
tried to do an Indiegogo and I was just
going through my my emails people I had
um you know email emails and [ __ ] and I
found someone upon your email because we
worked together on a film and uh he saw
that I was trying to do this Indiegogo
campaign he said what are you trying to
do here what's going on it's like I'm
trying to raise like thirty thousand
dollars to make this killer clown movie
and he was like I'll give you the money
tomorrow he's like I just want to be
able to work with you because I know you
do special effects and I'm interested in
special effects I want to just like be
by your side while you're doing this and
I think it would be fun and literally
the next day he gave me the money which
like hardly ever happens I mean he just
really stepped up to the plate and gave
me the money yeah what the [ __ ] what's
your name and can we hang out
what was that all about is that is it
really were you just interested in the
special effects process into the mic
Mike does that work okay there you go
there you go I'm not used to this
um I had just done a film and he had
worked on it with me
um I was always into film but I wanted
to have a family and I knew my talents
weren't there to be a film star I want
to be an actor you know with a face like
this a better for radio
um so I uh you know I wanted to make a
movie when I retired from my real job I
decided I was going to make a movie and
I met him I love that that is [ __ ]
tremendous wow so it's late in life like
a lot of artists uh version and youth
right because youth [ __ ] rules and
youth is like oh [ __ ] it'll never end
and it'll always work youth is
capricious as [ __ ]
um when we get aged and [ __ ] we know
how the world works less people tend to
reach toward art but that is the time to
do it man like play when you're older
you play when you're a kid and then they
force you to grow up and into the real
world and stuff but those of us that do
this kind of nonsense for a living
figure out that like oh [ __ ] if I get
this right I can play right to the
[ __ ] grave and again it happens early
in Youth for a lot of people to be
finishing up one life and not wrapping
it up but instead being like you know
what now it's time to do the thing I
always [ __ ] dreamed about that's
[ __ ] the noble work you're breathing
rarified air give it up thank you
well I got to give props to my wife all
right because yeah it was man [ __ ]
hey you have to you have to have a
strong woman behind you
um she's very strong and um she backs me
on everything I mean Damien burned down
on a house
we have more body parts in my basement
right now than Can Be Imagined and all
she does is go are you kidding me and
that's the end of it I mean you know and
then five minutes later she'll go do you
need help
so um you know she's called Mike I
needed body parts took her took my
daughters it was it was always but I
wanted to learn special effects I was
always creative too when I was younger I
used to draw I used to make comic books
and everything
but
I saw in Damien something that I don't
see often in people
um I've had a lot of Partners in my life
that I worked with and I only had one
that I ever felt that I could trust and
he'd have my back and I'd have his
always and I'm like that you know I
could shake your hand i'm your buddy for
life if you [ __ ] me you know got a
problem
Damien what if you [ __ ] you and you're
really good at it though well then then
we could talk even more fair enough I
just want to know if there were levels
yeah yeah but uh Damien is the real deal
I saw that very early on you know
definitely Dynamite guy I wish I had
known how good he was with special
effects when I did Jose
I thought he was just going to squirt
blood out and I was like all right just
make blood come out of here I'm blood
come out here
when I worked with him on terrify you
and we were doing things and I was like
you know he he was more conscious of the
money than I was at that time and he's
like you know we're going to do this and
I was going well why don't we just
freaking mold the whole body and
wouldn't it be and he goes that's that's
a lot of money it's [ __ ] it let's do it
it's going to look better let's [ __ ]
do it and now on terrify you too every
time he said well we're going to reshoot
I was going like [ __ ] no
we got to stop this [ __ ] but then he'd
go come on it's going to look so much
better [ __ ] it all right let's do it but
I learned a lot
um
and uh he's a good teacher and he's a
good friend
I love you buddy thank you same here
so you get it all done for 50. that was
the the idea yeah then what'd you do
this is the most important part for
those out there a lot of people a dream
of making flicks uh nobody knows where
to begin but nobody knows where to begin
once the [ __ ] most momentous step is
taken you can make a [ __ ] thing and
you're breathing rarified air and you're
one of like you know a one percent of
the world they'll ever create a piece of
art and [ __ ] try selling it that's the
next [ __ ] Hill just when you're done
it's like okay now what the [ __ ] do we
do with it what the [ __ ] did you do with
it yeah I believe if I remember
correctly we got a sales agent and he
started shopping in around to
Distributors and Distributors would
either come back saying they're not
interested or they want to take it but
they don't want to give us nmg which is
a minimum guarantee which is money up
front and then there were other people
who wanted it but they wanted to cut
some of the violence out and things
which I was not willing to come right
there were people yeah like too much
splatter yeah too much they didn't
understand that was like part of the
[ __ ] charm no not not at all yeah and
then and then we got to the point where
we were like all right we're just gonna
[ __ ] self-distribute this because you
know we don't want to compromise the
vision we knew that the gore was going
to be one of the most important aspects
of the movie and then I remember I had
um the DVD of Rob Zombie's 31 because
I'm a huge Rob Zombie fan yeah and uh
and on on the DVD there's a quote from
Steve Barton saying something positive
about the film and I knew that I I his
name sounded familiar and I knew that he
had known the producer of All Hallows
Eve somehow I wound up getting his email
address and I sent him an email saying
hey Steve would you mind checking out
this movie that I just made and I all I
wanted him to do was take a look at it
and if he liked it give us a quote to
say like all right maybe build some hype
say this movie's cool it's worth
checking out and so literally he's like
yeah I'll check it out and like the next
day he emails me back he calls me and
he's like dude what's going on with this
movie I'm like what do you mean I'm like
nothing I'm like we're trying to sell it
he's like don't do anything with this
[ __ ] movie he's like hold it he's
like this is what everybody in the
slasher genre is like waiting for this
is like art the clown is the next
[ __ ] big thing I'm telling you he's
like I just it's real yeah man it's a
true story
yeah
yeah he said I just got hooked up with
this company they're Distributing films
he's like I'm gonna convince them that
they need to pick this up no matter what
and and that's what happened they wound
up giving us in like an mg that we were
happy with and they put it out and they
wound up getting it on Netflix which is
brought it to another tier and that's
what really uh you know got it popular
when did when did you guys hit
profitability when were you paid back to
the place where you're like [ __ ] hey
that worked out on on the mg is that
right really yeah yeah so that's and
that's breathing rare air kids uh
generally nowadays your mg if you get
one if you're lucky enough to get one
most people are just like oh we'll put
it up and whatever we make we'll split
with you or something if you're lucky to
get a mg you don't get an mg that covers
your entire [ __ ] budget that just
doesn't happen anymore but I believe
that probably had a lot to do with how
low the budget was correct uh oh yeah by
the time we get to the Netflix moment
that's got to be just gravy because at
that point never mind sales that's
introduced you to the masses in a way
that like you know when I was a kid that
we didn't have that sort of [ __ ]
thing like horror now uh used to be you
could fill a movie theater now you could
go directly into their homes and stuff
what was it like
what was the netflixization of terrifier
like for you uh we would start seeing
celebrities posting it on their
Instagram they were filming it they were
talking about it um and we started
seeing a lot of people popping up with
tattoos dude I see this [ __ ] tattoo
right there that is incredible
amazing yeah things like that it was
just yeah it just became so much more
popular because so many eyes were on it
now and like I said that was the story
that I just kept hearing because David
and I do David Howard Thornton plays
Arthur clown we do a lot of horror
conventions and when people come up to
us there
oh [ __ ]
who's up there that's David Howard
Thornton uh yeah yeah Catherine Corcoran
who plays Dawn in part one and Jenna
canell who plays Tara in terrifier one
the Giant floating head of Oz
[Applause]
yeah
in here
so yeah it really I think we're delayed
it really brought it to another level
and so many people had eyes on and we
were just hearing from everybody that we
had you know and then we're like making
lists of like top horror movies and
things like that just because of how
popular Netflix is and it's so
accessible so at that point did you know
when you were doing terrifier that you
would want to do a terrifier too or is
it based on no the reaction no no always
because actually at the beginning of
tariffar1 originally at the end I did
not stop calling it terrifier one that
really irritates me you didn't call it
that the first time don't retcon that
[ __ ] terrifier
so at the end of terrifier uh originally
that scene with him resurrecting in the
morgue was not there so it just ended
with him blowing his brains out and then
it goes to the reveal that Victoria is
the woman from the beginning awesome so
when I was cutting it that by the way it
was a nice piece of writing oh thank you
as I was sitting in the back I was like
oh right on we're back where we started
how horrible
I said like I know that I'm not done
with this character and I want to bring
him back and I don't want the audience
wondering is he coming back is this it
well there so I was like we have to have
a scene where the audience knows he's
coming back and as cliched as it is I
said we have to have him pop up in the
morgue sort of you know Friday 13 part 4
style and uh and then we'll set it up
but they're gonna know he's Supernatural
and there's a lot more going on with
this character so we did go and reshoot
that scene because I knew I wanted to
make another one it's weird as I was
watching the flick
um it that seemed not a part of it where
it was just like wait we just went
Supernatural I thought it was more
Halloweeny my take on the flick was the
first one was very Halloweenish and then
the second one was very Nightmare on Elm
Street very much was that nightmare
number Street Dream Warriors it was like
it was very much a dream Warrior's
[ __ ] vibe to it and then [ __ ] for
some reason seeing Chris Jericho and it
really brought that home for me
um okay so at that point you add a scene
and is that before the movie comes that
the movie hits Netflix and all that yes
yeah so by then you're like oh I know
I'm going to do this again
um how many years between the first and
the second
um
2016 the first one came out and then I
think 28 October of 2018 we started
shooting part two oh [ __ ] nice so
that was like right on top of it so you
were shooting were you done right before
the pandemic oh you're before pandemic
hit in the in the middle of shooting
Terror part two is that right yeah yeah
yeah
did you think you caused it
wouldn't be surprised
um tell them what it's like to make a
movie during the pandemic
honestly for for us it was a huge
benefit don't tell me why yeah because
all right so when I wrote this script it
was uh it was super ambitious it was so
much bigger than part one and the
effects were just like gargantuan so I
told Phil I said dude for the we're not
going to be able to do this ourselves
we're going to have to hire another team
to come in and shoot like 40 percent of
the effects I mean you know tackle 40 of
the effects so he's like all right yeah
why just by sure but you like I can't do
it all by myself anyways yeah and you
know and I like literally do it all so
like I have to put Arts prosthetic on
holy [ __ ]
yeah I get I'm like the first person on
set I put Arts prosthetic on I literally
like do the the effects on set so I'm
like pumping the blood I'm like you know
like I have help like we had to have
help come in but like I do almost
everything
um so most directors like get there you
know and have one job to think about you
get there and do a whole job before you
start the job you're there for yeah
that's pretty it's pretty intense yeah
it's ambitious
um so we hired this company and we were
just going back and forth about the
budget and how much we could pay them
and they were like at first it seemed
like they were on board and we actually
started buying all these materials and
shipping it to them and then like a
month went by and they're like we can't
come to an agreement because we need a
lot more money so we were just like
screwed so now we were like so much
closer to shooting and now we didn't
have this team willing to help us out
have they given you an estimate
um did they I don't remember do you
remember they actually agreed to a price
did they and they came back and agreed
to a price and they actually started
um and then they said uh now we need
this we need that we and we said you
know
that ain't gonna work we already made an
agreement you know you already made and
he said well we can't do that and we
said uh all right then forget it yeah
and then at that point are you like I'm
back to doing everything myself back to
everything so I said to Phil I said well
what do we do when I said he said listen
we can't keep postponing this movie will
never get made Let's just jump in and
we'll figure it out as we go so all that
meant was we would have to just like
shoot up until a point when we didn't
have anything ready to go and we'd have
to break for like two weeks and then
Phil and I would just go in his basement
and build all the special effects for
two weeks and then
bring the movie back on we just know for
those that don't know how movies work
and stuff uh once you start you go until
you're done because every day costs
money and if you stop starting again
costs more money because you've ramped
the engine back up again and stuff so
that's why once a movie begins
traditionally they'll shoot 30 days two
months whatever [ __ ] it is a Marvel
movie they shoot nine years and stuff
but you start and then you go until
you're done uh particularly in the world
of low budget film so for you guys to go
and then stop and then go build a bunch
of [ __ ] and then start again prolongs
the process did it raise the budget or
did it ameliorate the budget for you
guys by breaking like that how to raise
it a little bit it it cost us a couple
of dollars here and there and one other
thing he would say like what are we
going to think we can't we can't move
back we can't do this we can't do that
and then I'd go all right we'll move
some money from here we'll put it over
there we'll worry about this later let's
get this done filmmaking is a criminal
Enterprise yes it's all about hiding
money but um one of the things that we
did that uh that worked out was we shot
a lot up in my place Upstate New York
and we built the sets ourselves so saved
a lot of money there right
um saved a lot of time too because like
you know you grab a couple of people you
go you you know as long as you don't let
Jason leave he's measure anything you're
okay
um and you and you you build whatever
you can and you have people like Olga
Turka that comes in and Designs the [ __ ]
out of it with her counterpod Jackie
Hughes
um so they make they make even the worst
set you could build look amazing and um
so we saved a lot of money there but it
was time consuming but what we would do
is we would
any downtime we had where we had the
actors and actresses maybe sleeping we
were doing something else and then I'd
sleep when they're acting
it worked for me high compliment to
every actor I slept through your
performance
but where where it really helped us was
we knew going into part two that we had
to create a scene a kill scene that at
least rivaled the hacksaw scene because
everybody wants to know how you're going
to top the hacksaw scene from terrified
when you said the access even cutting a
woman in half we cut we cut it was so
fun yes it was unbelievable I was
sitting in the back owing like no no
clear oh my God he did we show it we
show it all really it was uncanny so at
that point you're like I have to do
something bigger than that bigger yeah
and I um you know where you know where
do you go from there and I remember I
was in Barnes and Noble one day I was
flipping through a book about Jack the
Ripper and it was about it was a book
you know claiming that he could have
been a woman I believe and I was just
very curious and I was flipping through
and there happened to be an actual
photograph of one of his victims in it
and it was so disturbing and it was just
this poor mutilated woman on a bed you
couldn't even tell it was a human being
anymore but you know being me I was like
all right that's a perfect you know kill
scene for art the clown I felt so bad
for I exploited her
take that image and you know let's
reverse engineer it and if art the clown
was responsible how did that poor victim
end up in that state uh so I said that's
a good way to start but when this whole
thing happened with the other special
effects team we didn't have the effects
ready and we had to jump in and start
shooting that scene I remember being on
set with the effects we had prepped and
I was like this is going to be nowhere
near the hacksaw scene like no one's
going to be happy with this I said we're
gonna have to go back and shoot reshoot
this eventually and then we got hit with
the pandemic and the lockdown I said
it's a perfect opportunity to
reconfigure this entire scene I could
start from scratch you know go to the
drawing board and then I called Phil and
I called David and I said listen we're
going to do this whole thing over again
I have all this time so I'm going to
build all these really crazy special
effects sequences that we can put into
this whole kill scene they were like all
right yeah let's do it and we I took all
the time to build all those special
effects now to you know as best as we
could and then we took a whole week to
shoot that one scene and it really I
mean that's the scene I'm gonna I'm
gonna imagine is the one that had people
like freaking out and puking in the
theater and having panic attacks and so
it was that legit we saw that on the
internet there were people puking and
stuff that was legit I could swear to
you that we had nothing to do with that
it wasn't a market employer publicity
stun all
right yeah exactly I wish it was small
enough to do it yeah it's funny you're
like we didn't do that yes you did
um no I remember I saw a screening with
George stuber my my DP we were in the
city and when we were coming home from
that screening out we were in the lift
and I'm just like scrolling through like
Instagram or whatever and I see someone
saying my friend or someone behind me in
the screening of terrifier 2 literally
passed out in my theater and like
cracked their head on the back of my
chair I'm like what and then I saw
someone else saying this just happened
in terrifier too and it's like a picture
of puke like in the you know in the
theater and I'm like is this dude like
is this really happening and then sure
enough it just spreads it's like you're
Oscars man
my badge of honor yes you know
listen whether they're real or not I
assure you that we did not do it that's
all I uh well I could say but how long
was the shoot on terrifier then with the
start stop start stop two yeah almost
three years from start to finish to make
two yeah now uh again for conventional
wisdom
um would dictate like oh my God if you
knew that going in most people wouldn't
start
but that's how the movie got made like
that would there was no alternative no
other way
um would you advocate well I guess you
have to Advocate it's like any way the
movie gets made shy of killing somebody
is a good [ __ ] thing so it don't
matter if like most of the time it's
supposed to take this amount of time if
it takes a protracted a period of time
that's okay there are no [ __ ] rules
whatsoever
um how do you keep continuity across
three [ __ ] years continuity is like
everything looks like it's been shot in
the same period of time so three years
like a lot [ __ ] it out it like if if we
were to make a movie with me over the
course of three years I would look so
[ __ ] different right now from when we
started the movie so how did you guys
manage that over a couple years a
miracle the movie Gods just like you
know smiling upon us like I don't even
know I can't even tell you the only
thing that really kind of stands out is
you might actually be able to see Elliot
Fulham kind of grow of course I was like
what a special effect
yes yeah there's nothing we could do
about that it was like Prosthetics that
was just Boyhood oh like yeah oh and he
was in his prime of his voice cracking
throughout that entire movie I had to do
some magic some some editing some sound
design magic to tweak his voice and cut
out all those cracks and everything
speaking editing who's your editor who
cut me did you as well [ __ ] Jesus
Christ when do you sleep yeah um I was
very impressed with the editing as a
veteran myself I was like oh I [ __ ]
like that I liked it like right in the
way in the beginning of terrifier just
how quickly you brought us into the
story of cuts and it's something you
continued on in two as well you got a
style oh thank you and you could see it
man I dug it I was vibing on it as an
editor I was like oh I like that um it
also allows for [ __ ] like there's no
such thing as a bad special effect when
you cut that quick it felt like right
because there are moments where you have
two three seconds of something and then
you never use another piece of it and as
the editor I was sitting in the back on
like that could have went way wrong and
it wouldn't have mattered he got what he
needed out of it oh thank you dude like
I heard you talk about seeing which is
amazing you saw Friday the 13th part
four in this yeah yeah do you want to
hear a sad story about this yes so
father 13th 4 is that the one with the
kid in it the heavy kid no that's part
five five yeah so I saw oh I saw four
and I saw five and then this is a sad
story about five
um we're in this [ __ ] theater right
here man and I'm sitting like [ __ ]
about eight rows up and it's uh me I was
with Ernie uh we were with our friend uh
Danny hapstack and he had a brother
named Eddie abstek who was a few years
older and so that kid who's a heavy set
kid and he's eating chocolate and he's
kind of a little bit slow the characters
pretty slow
um he's on screen in a in a full [ __ ]
close-up with chocolate over his mouth
and [ __ ] like that in the Dead Silence
of the theater Ed hapstick Full House
like this on a [ __ ] Friday night Ed
hapstack goes it's [ __ ] Kev Smith and
and it was like it's not like I am now
where people like kept Smith he made
clerks but it was it was I was kid there
was only about 10 people who knew but
they were laughing and I was like oh
[ __ ] I said I'll never live this town
until one day I grow up and buy the
[ __ ] theater yeah and then I'll burn
it down with everyone in there
um but anyway yes four was the one that
did it for you that was if yeah so that
was the one that Tom savini did the
special effects on part one he did all
the effects on part one part four he did
it with a couple of other uh makeup
artists but the way the effects are shot
in that one they're edited really fast
but they're really graphic and I always
love that style right so I tried to
capture that just like a lot of
subliminal kind of like really grotesque
shots but don't Linger on them too long
um I mean I Linger on some things a lot
all that [ __ ] hacksaw scene
yeah but they could be longer you could
linger that's true it is possible but um
not much longer but yeah she could I
guess yeah um all right so what do you
since you're doing a piece mail over the
course of a few years did you have a
budget on terrify or two or was just
like it costs what it costs
we had a budget
that we didn't follow very well
what was the original budget
um we always went in thinking uh we were
going to do it like it's gonna be
similar to part one yeah well when
truthfully when
he hates when I say it but I'm not a
horror fan
what
the Santa's not real oh [ __ ] so um when
you know when we I went to a con with
them in Arizona the first time I went
and it was right as it went on Netflix
right before right before Netflix and
one of the things I was telling him was
we need to build a fan base and you'll
see I said we're going to get screwed on
terrify one which you hate to hear
um so we're going to get screwed on
terrify I said but we need to build the
fan base and if we build a fan base
we'll make our money on two
so when I went to Arizona and I'm
looking around and people coming up to
us and I'm like how the [ __ ] did I even
know who we are
not that they knew who I was I was
invisible then too but they were coming
over to Damien and Dave and I was like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on here how
do these people notice so I'm looking
and I go
Damien how long is Freddy Krueger out
and he's telling me and I'm asking him
about all these people and I said [ __ ]
we got to go bigger I said we got to go
big aside I had told him I said we got
to do at least 150 000.
and that was our original budget and
then when we started looking at the
script that he wrote I said oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that ain't gonna happen and we built
from there and um well then we did the
Indiegogo campaign because yeah and how
did that go how successful was that
incredible because you've already built
a name and uh and a franchise by this
point yeah we knew we had we definitely
knew we had a fan base but we didn't
know how big it was and um there was a
the clown Cafe scene that you see now in
terrifier too
um I just knew that was such a big scene
and we were going to kill so many people
it was going to be a big set and I just
knew with our budget there's no way we
can do this so I said let's reach out to
the fans and see if we could raise some
more money to incorporate this scene so
we set the goal for fifty thousand
dollars and then within like 12 hours it
went to like 250 000 and that was a huge
eye-opening moment I was like oh my God
I was like all right maybe we have
something a lot bigger than we thought
we had yeah thank you guys seriously
so at that point is that become the
budget or that it did so budget was too
fitty yeah and that enabled us to pretty
much create everything that I wrote In
The Script all two hours and 18 minutes
that you see now we filmed everything
that was the bossiest aspect I know I
was like oh we're gonna go long as [ __ ]
like most horror movies tend to be as
short as [ __ ] like 90 minutes sometimes
under
um this was just like no you're gonna
watch this
I have thoughts and you're going to see
them all
um okay so the budget winds up being
250.
um nobody in this room is a stranger to
these facts but for those who might be
tuning in at home going like what the
[ __ ] where are you guys right now in
terms of box office
with us in uh Canada like 11.8 Jesus
Christ put it together man holy [ __ ]
and then um with with streaming with
three weeks of streaming we're over two
mil
streaming two million dollars worth of
streaming so like 14 million dollars
yeah oh my God for a 250 000 budget yeah
um have who Who Came Calling first Jason
Bloom anybody like [ __ ] if I read
that I'm hiring the [ __ ] out of you for
like 96 things who's come calling since
the successive too it's been interesting
man like my whole life has been [ __ ]
turned around right now is that right
yeah yeah man I got to meet with Sam I
did a zoom meeting with Sam Raimi his
company
which is
dude
like Evil Dead 2 since I'm [ __ ] four
years old it's been one of my favorite
movies of all time I've been watching it
since I'm four years old and to see that
guy you know to talk to that guy I had
to stop the zoom I was like dude I need
to just Fanboy out and tell you how much
was he wearing a suit was he wearing a
suit he wasn't wearing a suit no no he
doesn't respect you yet yeah no not yet
on set he always wears suit he like
comes to I know directed his Hitchcock
thing right he says buddy still say
buddy a lot he's like hey buddy I love
terrifier buddy you know who he is did
you ever see um HUD sucker proxy yes
he's that guy who's like oh buddy that's
literally who the Cohen Brothers based
it on it's [ __ ] Sam Raymond yeah so
wait what'd you guys talk about so I
have another
um treatment another Horror Story That's
not terrify related that uh his company
is interested in putting into
development all right who else did you
hear from um I spoke to 824 I spoke to
new line Cinema like a lot of people
have been reaching out and we're just
interesting where were these [ __ ]
before yeah exactly yeah now everyone
comes calling when you know how to do it
now wait we we skipped a big important
uh step who put it out the second time
who distributed second time first time
oh yeah yes a company called cinidime
and uh they're in conjunction with uh
Bloody Disgusting so and dude like they
got behind it they believed in
everything about it they didn't care
about the violence they didn't care
about how long it was which is very
unprecedented and to just like put that
movie into mainstream theaters not being
raided and being that long is ridiculous
and you're talking about a sequel to an
obscure slasher film and they were like
look man we're gonna like put all our
eggs in your basket and just like hope
for it and they were hoping that if it
did well because they were trying to get
um their streaming platform a screen box
up and running as well and then you know
they really was hope we're hoping that
terrifier two would be a good push for
it if it was successful you know and it
worked out for them it really did I mean
they took a Gamble and it paid off so
I'm really happy about that but they
were awesome they were just so [ __ ]
supportive
amen Now take me into the cast here
which sounds way dirtier than I meant it
how uh how do you uh how do you arrive
at your cast uh we'll start right here
tell me
all right so
yes and that one oh [ __ ] that's right
maybe we should start with our entire
one how about we start with David
hey
I don't know if they can hear you I
think you're delayed
can they hear me yes we can hear you
okay we're good all right yeah so all
right so this is actually an interesting
story they're not all interesting that's
art the clown that's Arthur clown I know
it's such a disappointment
it's not a disappointment like you're
cute
so how how does he wind up his art so he
was not originally art the clown I told
you I made two short films before All
Hallows Eve those short films were put
into all houses so that was my buddy
Mike Gianelli so when I was getting into
makeup effects and he was just my friend
and I'd say like dude I need to you know
test this bullet hit on you or I have to
put this prosthetic on you and then it
was like dude I'm making my first
official short film I have this clown
character I know you don't act but I
just gotta all you gotta do is sit there
and smile and honk a horn and do all
this kind of [ __ ] I'm like I already
have your face mold you can do this
trust me I'll tell you I sat in the back
I was like this shit's awfully Silent
Bob
yeah I called my lawyer he said I
couldn't do [ __ ]
oh
yeah I wasn't a clerks fan or anything
yeah but uh so then we you know it's
just like he thought he was going to be
in this one short film and then it kept
going and going and before you know it
I'm like all right dude we're gonna make
terrifier the movie now and I need you
for months and he's just like dude I'm
not an actor I can't go through all this
makeup it's a lot and then and he was
like getting heavier and I wanted him to
go on a diet and lose weight
you Hollywood piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] size
this [ __ ]
you're what's wrong with this business
Damian fair point but uh listen I always
imagine art the clown to be skinnier I
thought skinnier and would be a lot
creepier and I just said dude you know
you got to get back to looking like the
way you looked in nine Circle long story
show he didn't want to do it so now I
said [ __ ] you know everything that
worked about Ninth Circle was Art the
clown like everybody whatever I did they
just loved that character for all the
other faults they loved art now I got to
start from scratch so we held this
audition in the city you know in
Manhattan just an open call to have
people come in to play this silent mime
killer clown I think it was uh obviously
a killer clown in the in the size and
then Dave walks in and he's like oh hey
what do I do he's like I didn't have any
sides and I'm like I don't worry you
don't need sides I'm like you're uh
you're the silent killer clown and why
don't you just act like you're killing
somebody decapitating them but you're
doing it very gleefully you'll have it
you're having a very good time doing
this and he goes oh oh all right and
then he just like flips this switch and
goes into this amazing performance where
he's cutting off this guy guy's head and
ripping it off and then he'd Taste the
Blood and he's like not satisfied with
it and then he goes and takes a salt
shaker and he pours it onto the blood
and tastes again he's like that's great
and then he skips out of the room like
the [ __ ] Grinch and the whole time
it's just me and Phil in the room and
I'm like nudging him and we're laughing
and I'm like wow this is this is good
this is good and he looked like I wanted
him to look he was tall and thin and he
had this big smile this big grin when he
walked in I said physically he would
look amazing in that makeup and I was
just like hope he just doesn't blow it
with the audition and he killed it with
the audition and then I was like all
right man we'll be in touch and he was
like the sixth person to come into the
room and then he left and I looked at
Phil and I go well what else are we
really looking for I'm like this guy's
perfect he looks perfect that was
fantastic that's more than I even
thought we were gonna need I said let's
have this guy come back let's throw the
prosthetic on him and let's film it and
see how that works and that was I like
shut down the auditions there he was the
sixth person to come in for art the
clown I just knew that was the guy David
have you done anything prior to that
um not film wise I was a stage actor
um I had just finished up my fifth
national tour of How the Grinch Stole
Christmas the musical so I it was quite
a leap going from my you know family
friendly like musical theater to pull on
you know NC 17 horror so that was a fun
jump
um what uh do me a favor man can you
give us a taste of your audition that
got you the [ __ ] job
oh my God
I I know it's online but um it's like I
I just
coming in just
okay
Cinema history is made
dude that was it to a t that was it man
that was it and that was the aristocrats
what is uh how is the makeup to wear
I've gotten used to it we've um changed
up some
um we used to use a gelatin mask that
would fall apart easily because of like
any moisture and now we've changed it up
to a foam latex mask and so much lighter
on me and doesn't fall apart nearly as
easily
and what is the like in your life when
did people start figuring out that you
were art the clown and was it [ __ ] up
yeah
um people I I think people are slowly
starting to figure that out now I I
sometimes get recognized on the streets
which surprises me because you know this
does not look like art at all so but
it's it's slowly starting to happen in
sinking in like I had an Amazon delivery
guy the other day recognized me and I
was like wow that's that's crazy
he also wears a terrifier shirt wherever
he goes
merchandising
taken from a guy who's wearing a Silent
Bob shirt right now good move yep yep
all about the advertising
um take us uh else who else is up behind
me all right so then we have Catherine
Corcoran who plays Dawn in part one
the infamous hacksaw scene which she is
clearly the MVP of terrifier I always
say that and she was listen that's not
an easy scene to film by any stretch of
the imagination being upside down is
[ __ ] like not comfortable right with
clothes on yeah she'll tell you about
that
um but she was adamant about making that
scene as cool as it could be I remember
having the first meeting with her I met
her where she lived we had coffee just
to talk about the role and she said
listen if we're gonna do this let's make
it the coolest kill scene you've ever
seen like we're gonna go let's go all
the way and let's like really have
people talking about this scene and I
said listen that's where I'm coming from
I plan on doing that like I want this to
be a show stopper I want everybody
leaving the movie talking about this
scene and uh and everything you see
there's no trickery I mean she's really
hanging upside down by her ankles you
know in that scene in that dingy
disgusting room that was in the middle
of the winter it was freezing no heat it
was a real abandoned building it was
actually condemned we got yelled after
being in there listen to YouTube creeps
man he was so happy it was actually
condemned
[ __ ] Adams Family up here
uh how did it feel Catherine hanging
upside down at what point were you like
why did I interacting
you are supposed to have a rig to do
something like that and Jenna can speak
to this more than I can because she is
like her stunt abilities run circles
around mine but we both you know
actively do stunts and
um you are supposed to have a rig and
you know with the budget that they were
working with that just wasn't there it
wasn't it wasn't possible so
um the the compromise that we came up
with was that um you know I was going to
be on a on a platform and we were going
to be upside down for I think it was
like 42 seconds at a time so that I
wouldn't risk seizure and um and we
would we would yell action and there
would be a timer and we would remove the
little platform I was on we could never
take my legs out of the uh the uh
shackles those were real shackles uh
because it would take too long so
um we took they would take them out and
I would reverse crunch down and then um
we'd go for as long as we could get it
and then the time would run out and and
we'd yell cut and they would all come in
and push me back up Phil was often the
one who had to hoist me
um up onto the platform and that's what
we did all night in 20 degree weather
um and at a starting point
um I did start to get like a little bit
like nauseous I remember that
um so the one close-up I think when you
just see her head where I'm hanging off
a table
um and I did get really sick afterwards
and did have to have a minor medical
procedure which we now talk about
lovingly but it was definitely a moment
where I was like and I think afterwards
like is this is this the job I'm not
sure
um I'm not totally sure but I mean
exactly how Ben Affleck started so yeah
that's the job
so I was like
um so when we when but the funny thing
is is the scene everybody says Made
horror movie history and is what really
makes the film memorable and
um you know I'm really honored to have
that and when we were filming it Damien
I remember going into the abandoned
building and or condemned building
whichever it was and um and Damien
saying uh are you ready to make horror
movie history and I was like shut up
Damien nobody is going to watch this
film I was actually filming with Ernie
from Smart Castle on my off days we were
making another horror movie
simultaneously and I was just like No
One's Gonna watch this and here we are
with you guys what seven years later and
I just like God maybe maybe I should
listen to people or something I don't
know I guess based on what I saw you
should never listen to your agent [ __ ]
they didn't want me to do it they were
not happy about it I believe it it's a
wise choice
yeah but I wanted to so here we are let
me ask you this what is the um what's
the recognition Factor how often are
somebody like oh my God you're the woman
that got sawed in half
that's a lot actually the other day I
was having a hard time finding Park
at the LA Convention Center because I
was speaking about women in genre for La
Comic-Con and uh like there was like a
parking issue and I pulled up and um I
like went to ask an attendant if like
there was another lot and I pulled the
window down and she was like
you the clown movie the the that's you
and I was like yeah I I think I know
what you're talking about that that is
me it's just like oh this way and I was
like sweet like paid off like how was
her how was her first question not like
how is your crotch
oh you know well
um
modern medicine
is a wonderful thing and um luckily you
know I I have healed in in um you know
in such a way that I feel is only made
me better but you know
um I I would I would encourage you to
ask Damien how his crotch is next time
um
as you know it would be fun to see that
happen to the office and sex once in a
while
yeah how come in terrifier too he didn't
split it like a dude from the [ __ ]
dick up cut the guy's dick off
why did you split him though like he did
her
um you did cut the dude
I have these questions too Kevin I
wasn't penetrating questions to say the
least
um you know what it's uh you're
breathing rarefied air when uh you can
claim an entire scene as your own you
know actors are often at the mercy of
the filmmaker and and uh you know become
a a prop in some degrees uh this is a
sequence where without the actor you
don't get to [ __ ] do that magic
sequence and without not just like an
actor but an actor who's willing to hang
upside down for longer than [ __ ]
humanly possible you cruel pieces of
[ __ ]
um give it up for a lazy job
thank you guys thank you who else we got
up there Damien
yeah and then we have Jenna canell who
plays Tara in terrifier
so Jenna I was uh trying to work with
for years a project before terrifier
that wound up falling apart we never
made it and then I said I'm always going
to come back I'm gonna get you in
something and then there was terrifier
and uh I don't even think you had an
audition for terrify it was just like
let's let's do this I know what you're
capable of and who you are and uh I
Edition for Ninth Circle night Sir The
Ninth Circle with my short film that I
was going to turn into a feature that
never happened but yeah
and so
what was your experience like on this uh
[ __ ] killer clown movie you stole
your job Kevin
question
[Laughter]
should I go more specific yeah please
um when you do something like terrifier
um and it like enters uh the public
Consciousness what does that do for
one's acting career or in this
particular case your acting career
I can't be more specific than that
sure no no that's that's that's plenty
specific
reason in other ways it's you know I
look very different in real life than I
do in the film and so I actually have
the opposite experiences these two where
uh I'll like I was on a film
um last year and the makeup artist was
doing my makeup and she was talking
about terrifier and was talking about
how much she loved it and I said
something about uh you know being
involved in it she said oh are you are
you friends with those guys
no
um I'm I I I'm the I'm the [ __ ] in the
skeleton costume and she like stepped
back and that that actually happens to
me more often is that usually people
will be working with me and then after
the fact we'll find out that I was a
part of this and then we'll lose their
minds and then suddenly
change
which is pretty amusing
there was a that was the moment where I
was like Jesus this guy will use
anything to kill people
um since it was a you know splatter
movie I expected like a lot of splatter
um I found it interesting as [ __ ] that
you used a gun as well yeah what's that
all about no judgment whatsoever I was
like oh my God nobody ever used a gun to
kill in a horror movie before like this
makes sense that's why I did I like uh
little personal challenges and to see if
things that would work that you don't
typically see and that's one of the most
polarizing parts of the movie some
people love it they think it's brilliant
and they think that he pulls the gun out
other people [ __ ] hysterical it's
hysterical I mean
um and it's but it's very I think it's
very fitting for art because it's very
cheap and it's very unfair and it's very
it's it's in characters
that's why we know it's fine
we all know it was a fair fight let's
get real taken down what he had to yeah
he was he was down and out last resort
he's like he's always got that in his
back pocket if he's got to pull it out
like I originally used the gun in the
short film terrifier he pulls it out and
because I wanted to see if it was
because guns are terrifying and they
could be like really horrifying they're
very relevant and so I thought you know
could I put that in the hands of a
character like Freddie or Jason and
actually have it work and so I just
wanted to try it out and since he does
use it he does use it kind of like a
slasher where he doesn't just use it
once he shoots her in the leg and then
he shoots her in the thigh and then he
shoots her in the stomach and he just
keeps going and prolonging it for as
long as possible and then when he
finally does kill her he doesn't stop
there then he just unloads the gun in
her face [ __ ] spoilers yeah
he just he mutilates her like art loves
you know facial mutilation that's his
that's his thing um so I like it I like
that he's he's cheap and he will resort
to anything and there are no rules and
the fact that he takes out the main
character in the middle of the movie
sort of Janet Lee style it sets up his
character is just being very
unpredictable and you can never you
never know what he's going to do and
nobody's safe and that really helps
going into terrifier too because it
keeps you on edge I sat in the back and
when when you were shooting her I was
like oh man she's gonna have a hard time
making it to the credits and [ __ ] uh but
I guess she'll be limping all the way
and then when you shot her like in the
body I was like Wow [ __ ] this is gonna
be even harder man can't wait to see
what challenges he offends for this
character and then he [ __ ] shot her
and then I was like what the [ __ ] not
the girl in The Skeleton dress I got
nobody now
yeah it is very gently you're right man
like suddenly it was like [ __ ] there she
goes well I can trust nothing in this
movie
um all right where else are we going
right here so Lauren levera terrifier
too
so I will I'm sorry I I could I have a
little a little more to say about this
woman so the character of Sienna is my
favorite character that I've ever
written even more than art the clown
believe it or not because she's very
close to me personally
uh because she's actually
um lightly based on my two older sisters
so I drew from a lot of personal
relationships and experiences and also
just like a little bit of me being an
artist and sort of like building the
costumes and things like that so um it
was so important to find the right
actress and when we started getting
um auditions like online and I saw
Lauren's real and I knew immediately
that she was just so talented and so
physical she had this background being a
martial artist that she would be
fantastic and then I brought her in uh
to read with Elliot who plays Jonathan
and their chemistry together was just so
amazing and I knew they were going to
elevate my you know the material and my
dialogue and everything so it was just
it was so amazing and then just seeing
her you know bring it to life and bring
her own experiences to the role it was
just one of the most like beautiful
experiences I ever had as a Creator and
it was just so amazing yeah you really
killed it so proud of you seriously take
us in the tube
is it intimidating joining a world that
already exists or do you feel like [ __ ]
there's some safety here man I know
people are going to see this [ __ ]
movie it's got a two in the title
um I actually didn't see the first
found out that I was cast which was a
mistake I should have watched it before
so I'd known what I was getting myself
into
um but no I loved it I watched it like
back to back like four times the same
day and I was like okay like what the
[ __ ] is this
um so I was taken out to dinner with uh
Dave and Damian and they kind and I just
felt really protected from the gecko
like they just I really felt like they
would have my back and um I don't know
if it was you or Dave that said it but
Dave said I'm pretty sure it was Dave he
said that Sienna was going to be the
Batman to Arts Joker and I was like what
are you saying what that that's a huge
statement Batman dude and then I look at
Damon he's like no it's true like
definitely and I was like all right cool
I didn't believe it like I was like sure
okay what the [ __ ]
um but yeah I don't know I just felt
really supported throughout and I I mean
even today I'm surprised that people
care like I'm happy I'm like grateful
but I don't know it's just like I said
everything is has been so unprecedented
we would have never guessed I mean maybe
they would have but I would have never
guessed that so many people would
identify with Sienna and terrifier too
so
I don't remember the question was but um
you got there you vamped enough what is
the what's the life been like since the
success of the movie do you how often do
you recognized at this point for that
for terrified this okay so I teach
kickboxing still because I like martial
arts it's my only catharsis outside of
uh acting and this morning this woman
came up to me and she was like can I fan
girl please and I'm like on my phone and
I'm like why and she's like what do you
mean why terrifier too I was like
you know about that I don't know like it
was just wild because I teach kickboxing
and like I don't know they're all like
middle-aged women I didn't think that
they would care and she was like oh my
God I love Indiana's so [ __ ] cool and
uh it was just wild I was like okay and
she was like can we take a picture I was
like please don't post this I don't want
people to know where I work
um
but no it's it's wild the way you teach
kickboxing now I do yeah where in Los
Angeles no I I'm from Philly Philly so
you do it in Philly
um so somebody could be like taking a
kickboxing class and be like oh if I was
a chick from [ __ ] terrifier too it
happened this morning I'm gonna learn
some [ __ ] you're gonna learn that you're
going to learn today that's for damn
sure
off topic question but how high can you
kid very high
you're not gonna do it come on man
[ __ ] Ducks dude like I'm wearing
Ducks is that hard
thank you
do you need a hand or something to kick
is this high or higher
don't hurt me what the [ __ ]
my God man
you get them on the way up and on the
way down with one of those I'm happy I
wear jeans today
um [ __ ] it takes a lot of physicality to
make a movie like this so you were
prepared as [ __ ] huh
I mean I wasn't entirely prepared but
yeah
she was super prepared yeah super
prepared not only physically but I say
this all the time nobody has ever cared
for a character that I wrote more than
me it's my own character it's like my
kid than she did I mean she would call
me every week I mean days and days like
just saying like what do you think you
know how do you think Sienna feels about
this like what kind of music do you
think Siena will listen to like made me
a playlist yeah and I gave her a
playlist yeah like I love what John
Hughes used to do that for The Breakfast
Club kids he made plays this is what you
would all listen to and [ __ ] I always
thought that was creepy
oh no that's a very very cool thing man
so and most importantly like the job of
director kids
um it seems very glamorous it seems uh
like oh [ __ ] that's the job tab it's a
very simple job uh everyone else's job
on a movie set is very easy to identify
directors is a little more vague
ultimately the job comes down to a
series of questions that's it you have a
movie in your head that nobody else can
[ __ ] see and so people come to you
constantly with like black or white and
a good director is just like Oh Black
it's always been black since I was five
and I went to see [ __ ] lost boys and
[ __ ] like that you just have the answers
for everybody at a moment's notice you
have to because you're the only one with
the movie in your head so when an actor
comes to you and asks you a series of
[ __ ] questions like you're the only
one that could provide all the context
to let that actor then take off and soar
and what I'm hearing here is that he was
crazy collaborative you've got like more
than what you needed absolutely I like I
thought I was being really annoying
because directors love that [ __ ] that's
like yeah it's like you love the
character
yeah no for sure yeah I
was like always available for me for me
day and night
and I am so grateful I'm so grateful for
that I mean really everybody on
terrifier too is fantastic but like he
was the captain of the ship so yeah I'm
super grateful if he would always answer
my questions and he was excited that I
was excited and I was like [ __ ] yeah
let's make this [ __ ] film let's do it
so
yeah
um it's a real sausage party this
[ __ ] movie because they're yet again
you've you're very female heavy
um which uh normally when I was growing
up female heavy was just like kill them
all and [ __ ] they were victims here
there's a lot of strength uh take us
over here
Samantha scaffidi who plays Victoria
yeah
I love Samantha so the final girl in
part one who sort of becomes Arts victim
and is now becoming uh some sort of evil
vile entity uh herself in part two and
there's a lot more to explore with her
character so
yeah yes that's me yes I'm disfigured in
the majority of uh my moments but this
is me now with a face hello
wait the
what was it like doing the the I was
gonna say it was like doing the creepy
scene they're all [ __ ] creepy
um what how do you approach a film like
this where your character is going to go
in very interesting directions to say
the least
I didn't know I feel like with the first
film I like I knew the script because
obviously I had read it prepared for it
but I didn't know really until the
second that
it would kind of evolve in this really
for me it's like one of the most
exciting evolutions of a character
because it's amazing to be a final girl
it's amazing to to kind of be a hero in
a film to a degree but then
for me it's really juicy where it's
I'm playing that and then all of a
sudden she's descending into madness and
where do I go with that where do we go
with that and questions I ask for Damien
it's like there is there any part of
Vicky that is still
in there and like and how do we explore
that together it's just a gift it really
is so it's yeah I'm just really well
yeah I don't know if I answered that
question but you did uh you are uh part
of a long story tradition in uh horror
movies final girl
um what is that uh like out in the real
world like there's a real uh following
for final girls all over the [ __ ] it's
like it's a concept it's the thing that
obviously people know so much so that
there's a term
it's I mean I'm I'm excited I'm grateful
for it um uh I don't I yeah I just
it's it's an honor and just like I said
when I met Damian and just being a part
of anything that he makes is an honor
and a privilege and I'm just excited to
be along for the ride and the fact that
ride has gotten extended and extended
has been just one of the highlights of
my career
so it's pretty cool how can I give it up
for Amanda excellent yeah
and then we have Sarah Voigt who plays
he and his mother Barbara and Tara fire
2.
now so this is acting how the [ __ ] are
you playing her mother man what are you
like two years [ __ ] older than her
that's the special effect in this
[ __ ] movie
yeah there I'm done being Charming
Sarah what was it like kind of playing
my mother in this movie is that who
she's playing a little bit is based kind
of yeah it's a little autobiographical
not gonna lie that whole family Dynamic
and terrified which by the way was very
good like I love the family scenes in
the beginning I was like oh [ __ ] like it
already took a jump from the previous
movie and as much as like look at the
performance though and look at the shots
and [ __ ] anyway back to this yeah
yeah
so
um I loved playing your mother
she's an Angry Angry Angry [ __ ] and I
adore her because my mother is very
similar
um Noah's great
did you know about terrifier going I
don't remember like did you know about
it have you ever been in a horror movie
before when you no I remember I I booked
it and then I watched one and my husband
turned around and said do you really
want to do this did you see what they
did to that woman
and I said no but I need the credit on
my IMDb
so that's how I suffered through
terrifier 2 which has become the
greatest achievement of my life
and yes
and uh how do you feel about mashed
potatoes now
you [ __ ] and your DMs with your
mashed potatoes which I am very great
people for it but my own mother trolls
me with potatoes
all day every day she's like you
were okay
I
have my face proper it was like my Dead
face
um but no I I do love mashed potatoes so
thank you
um and I love portraying your mother
did a great job you did a great job my
mother my mother hated you in the movie
which means I did a great job putting
that mirror right up to her face I don't
like her she I wouldn't believe what a
kind thing to do with a woman who's like
I'll help you finance your first film
like I would have believed that little
boy you're like I don't like her
speaking of little boy there he is yep
Elliot Fulham who plays Jonathan
hello now very heavily based on me is
just like interested in obviously murder
and dark [ __ ] and but but a good person
but a good kid at heart and um very very
difficult role to cast finding a little
kid who has the acting chops and who
could also sustain all that physical
[ __ ] that he has to go through and being
whipped by Art the clown and he you
really take a beating in this [ __ ]
movie I'm like
um so and you were you were incredible
dude you really were I'm very proud of
you and what you did thank you so much
yeah man
it was like growing up on this movie
well I kind of also grew up with the
first move because I was already a fan
of the first terrify before I even
auditioned so when I saw the audition I
terrified to no way how [ __ ]
refreshing all these other [ __ ]
are like I never heard of it but I
needed the work yeah
and you're like I was a [ __ ] fan I
came to it willingly I've been a horror
fan since I can remember a house of a
Thousand Corpses one of the first horror
movies I've ever watched at a very very
young age
it makes me feel so [ __ ] old man like
first horror movie I watched was like
when you were 40.
yeah so I've always been a hard nerd and
late to Jonathan because he's into all
the dark stuff I'm not into uh real
killers but I do love me some good
horror slashers
what uh when most of these uh other cats
are grown-ups in the grown-up world
you're still dealing in a world that
actually goes to see these movies so are
you something of a celebrity amongst the
youth set do they recognize you
instantly sometimes I I've gone out to
NYC and there will be people that stop
me oh you're that kid and terrifier too
yes yes
let's have sex
[Laughter]
I haven't gotten that yet
terrifier three you watch
yeah what uh
is it uh now it's not like a Marvel
movie but I imagine wealth shit's going
on you're like [ __ ] no spoilers to
[ __ ] keep [ __ ] quiet don't tell
people what we're doing and stuff don't
spoil gags is it tough to work on [ __ ]
that's cool and not tell people like oh
especially in the age of social media
like look at this they hacked a lady in
[ __ ] half it's nuts
it was I mean for sure far too yes it
was was pretty hard because you know uh
I am a horror nerd so I want to talk
about horror movies so I had to keep it
to myself until it eventually came out
and then I was able to talk about it so
uh I don't know anything for terrifier
three that's in Damien's Minds
I didn't ask but good [ __ ] covers
he's like I smell where this is going
don't ask me [ __ ] I want to come back
Steve did we have others that we didn't
get up here
yeah Kaylee
you are I'm getting up I'm leaving all
right thank you very much yeah producer
come on up kid
Kaylee Hyman who plays Brook in
terrifier two Sienna's friend
you don't want to know why
[Laughter]
what was your experience like I gotta
say just like Kaylee's audition like
there was there was never a runner-up
for Sienna or for Brooke as soon as we
saw their performances we said these are
the actresses for the part like Kaylee
just had like the most raw talent that I
saw seriously from all the auditions and
I literally gave her Direction one time
throughout the course of the movie so
like every like she just owned Brook and
like just told me who Brooke was I just
sat back at the monitor I just [ __ ]
washed in awe every take every and every
day she just brought something different
to it she would improvise and she was
just so alive every take and literally
there's this one performance when she's
talking about Sienna's uh father and she
didn't do it bad in any way it was just
I just wanted her to like just shift the
tone a little bit and she just did it
instantly and that was the only time I
really ever gave you any direction other
than blocking so you were just so
stunning you did such an amazing job so
yeah
thank you what was your did you know
about terrifyer I mean have you ever
acted in a horror movie before what did
you think you were getting into I've
never done a horror movie I I love
horror movies my brother and I watch
them we have like a Tuesday night horror
movie Fest at my house that we still do
but no I've
similarly I did not see terrifier one
until you called me you told me about it
I watched it and I was like
all right I'll do it
um it was great though it was I've I
just I'm so in awe of the um practicals
and the the special effects that you did
I mean I would scare myself at the like
the gash on my leg was so realistic I I
would just like send pictures and be
like Mom help and she'd be like what
there
um
oh man I just it was it was such an
awesome experience and also like very
cold
um I feel like we've talked about this
all the time it's very cold there
um just being on an indie film and
working on something and and working
long hours and really building up that
stamina in uh this group setting with
all of these amazing people that have so
much heart and just absolutely love what
they're doing I mean it was just the
best experience and I don't think
there's anything that could have
projected me in a way
um
to help me experience whatever is going
to come now I feel like I'm ready for
any set that I'm going to be on like
nothing is going to challenge me in that
way
in in such like a physical and emotional
way that I really went through with this
and now I also have like friends for
life and it was just I'm just so
grateful for it was this was this also
the first time you ever had condoms
glued to your face and a guy on the
other end blowing it no funny story
um no yes of course I've had condoms all
over my face I don't know what a condom
is
um
yes it is
it is um if anybody doesn't know yes my
my face had that that was what was
bubbling they were condoms and
um and there's one take that actually
did not make it in the movie where one
pops
do you I don't know what happened to
that but but right underneath where you
see in the film is Damien with a
struggling
any and I think he like laughed and blew
a little too hard and what pup and I was
like screaming and then like wait
because you're like my face is gonna get
pregnant can we keep this in right
uh what I keep hearing uh over and over
from the actors is a lot of love man you
have a family atmosphere for a movie
that's so [ __ ] horrible and gruesome
uh everybody uh all the performers
um uh love you uh and and seem to have
your back man and and coalesce Beyond
you that's uh
that's pretty powerful yeah and like you
know it's it we know for a fact these
[ __ ] aren't here for the money
for Christ's sakes one of them's here
for the credit but uh
but it sounds like they're all here uh
for the love
um how's that make you feel man the best
man and that that to see atmosphere that
I like to keep on set I'm so grateful
and unless we're just having fun I like
to keep that kind of childlike
atmosphere and if like anybody brings
any negative like I'll never snap on
anybody like it'll take so much for me
to ever get angry on set like ever it's
just you know I'm having such a good
time and such I like to keep a really
loving environment and we're all there
having fun it should be fun we're not
[ __ ] curing cancer or doing
performing brain surgery or anything
like that we're making movies we're
getting to play for a living so that's
why when anybody brings any negativity
to my set it's just like oh chances are
I'll [ __ ] get rid of them like the
next day unless there's some people I
know and really trust or they have a
reason to be annoyed which happens a lot
I mean we put people through really
stressful situations sometimes where
people crack we all crack there's all
moments throughout the movie where
people break you know you're on [ __ ]
18-hour days sometimes it's freezing
cold you're covered in blood you know I
get it but at the end like I'm always
there I'm always there to be your
support and um again I mean I want to be
even though it's uncomfortable I want to
be an enjoyable experience so I really
try and keep that atmosphere yeah
absolutely smart Steve is there anybody
else or is that it
you want to shout them out or yeah
Mike Levy here assistant director and
God knows how many goddammit it's about
time Damien
I've been sitting on that floor waiting
all damn night
I was trying to zoom in I was trying to
get up there but everybody else did did
technical difficult we got to work about
it Mike what's your what's your favorite
memory from the set of terrify one or
two one I was will the Exterminator okay
I was the guy I got decapitated the
first one great scene
happy to be here man it's just it's
incredible
it's an honor to be here with you bro
it's so weird to say that I was like you
were the Exterminator man [ __ ] I what
yeah you know it's funny I get me I get
text messages and and things they think
that uh hey you know that guy Dante from
clerks is the guy got exterminated from
the filming decapitated
I get that another movie all together
uh the uh
people out there who are watching a lot
of cats would like to do what you do and
horror is a conceivable entry in for a
lot of nascent filmmakers there are a
million ways out of this room and horror
is a path that a lot of first-timers
take so I would imagine there are a lot
of first-timers out there watching and
people who want to do what you've done
on a small level on a big level what
advice can you give those cats practical
advice from somebody who has done a
couple of terrifiers and made up a word
in the process that word doesn't exist
ladies and gentlemen is made up for the
movie tell them what they could do to be
you or be themselves yeah I mean listen
all I could say is what I did that
worked for me one thing is you know in
your heart what you want to be and if
you truly want to be that you'll never
stop no matter what no matter where you
end up you could end up on the street
starving and poor but you're going to
keep doing it because you don't know how
to do anything else and nothing else is
going to bring you Joy so if you really
believe that that's what you want to do
you won't even question it you'll just
keep doing it you won't have a choice
but to but to do it the other thing I
say if you really you should choose
something in the exploitation error it I
mean Arena it does help because I knew
that going in even as a kid when I was
making like my first short film I said I
have to show [ __ ] that's gonna get
people talking like there's so much
competition out there there's so many
movies everybody can make a movie now
with with their phones and whatnot why
is somebody going to watch your movie
that's this good point because going
into terrifier I said why is somebody
going to watch terrify when they can
watch a 20 million dollar Hollywood
horror movie what am I bringing to the
table that's going to get them talking
about my movie and I said we'll have
kill scenes that you've never seen
before and where other movies would shy
away I'm gonna show everything so we're
gonna have this great you know kill
scene this hacksaw scene where if they
had that in an R-rated movie they might
do it but you won't actually see the saw
going through her body and from certain
angles and things like that and even
Dave like Dave will tell you he said
when he read it he thought I just wrote
the description for the reader and he's
like we're not going to actually show
that obviously no I'm going to show
everything that I wrote in the script
and he's like oh my God like okay and we
did I mean and that was the mindset
going in and sure enough people did talk
about that scene and that's one of the
reasons why terrifier was so popular I
mean people start telling their friends
you got to check out the scene it's
crazy and then going into part two I
said we have to do something like that
again we're still a super low budget
movie a quarter of a million dollars is
like the budget of the [ __ ] craft
services on a Marvel movie you know and
that's our whole budget I said you know
why are people going to come watch this
movie and now we have these people
wanting us to rival the hacksaw scene
we're going to show people something
really insane let's have this kill scene
that takes place for like three minutes
in this brightly lit room like where you
see like the transformation seeing
American whale from London in this harsh
light but you see everything and that's
just not something you typically see in
slasher movies it's usually very quick
and it happens in the dark it happens in
Shadows but we'll show everything and
sure enough you know people are [ __ ]
puking leaving the theater
dollars so I recommend that you really
are conscious of just giving people
something that's going to stand out and
get them talking it doesn't have to be
something horrific but it has to be you
have to you don't want to just have
people talking around a table or
something philosophical until you've
already made a name for yourself and
then you already have their attention
and then you can do your movie with
people talking around a table but you
have to grab the audience's attention so
just be conscious of that
excellent piece of advice the uh you we
just watched a movie with the two in the
title and if you get to a two and it's
successful uh you know it screams
Trilogy uh how soon can one expect you
to start working on terrifier three well
I've already started writing the script
um but like I said there's a lot of um a
lot of people have come to the table now
and they're interested in working with
me on things and I do have other horror
ideas and ideas for films so it could
potentially be one movie in between
terrifier three or if none of those pan
out quickly I'm gonna just jump right
into Terror Party 3 and get it going
I'll tell you uh yes give it up
I'll tell you the good art creates good
artists or wannabe artists and and even
a wannabe artist is a good artist every
artist is a good artist
um
I sat in the back tonight and as I was
watching Terror fire too I was like oh
[ __ ]
um I should make my next movie [ __ ]
super cheap because then I could control
everything I was like what a good idea
and then I was like wait I made Clerks
I had this good idea years ago and I
forgot along the way because along the
way like life happens business happens
and suddenly all of a sudden things cost
more than they did when you started the
job but I was inspired tonight I sat in
the back and I afterwards I was talking
to Josh Rausch and he had talked about
this movie that I was talking about
making and uh it was we're gonna have to
go shoot it elsewhere or something and
he was like you should shoot it here and
I was like oh we can't it's too much
money after watching you guys tonight I
was like [ __ ] we are shooting it here
we're going to do inexpensively man
we're going to follow your lead so thank
you my friend wow from an elder
Statesman to a [ __ ] younger one
ever
[Applause]
um kids uh tonight you got to breathe uh
some rare air man you got to hang out
with some people that made cool ass
movies that you all just sat and watched
you have a good time tonight people have
Smart Castle
I want to thank the good folks from
Terror fire and Terror not terrifier one
just terrifier
uh and terrifier too not not only for
double featuring it tonight which is a
fulfilled a long time dream of mine for
this place and stuff uh but also for
sticking around and Q a into the [ __ ]
wee hours of the more it's 1 30 Kids 1
30 on the East Coast which means that a
bunch of people are still watching the
stream because they're a fans be hungry
for information tonight uh you both
entertain them and provided them with a
lot of information uh for those watching
on the stream and for those of us here
in the room you gave us a lot to think
about next time I'm hanging upside down
I'm gonna think about that [ __ ]
hacksaw scene
um kids uh
protect your crotch Kevin
I hear that all the time
kids uh the uh when you make nightmares
for a living you meet the people that
make nightmares for a living and they
turn out to be the sweetest dreamiest
[ __ ] people of all time give it up
for the cast and crew of Terror fire and
terrifier too
that's all we got for you from spot
Castle Cinemas good night kids come see
us in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey good
night thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]